okay so black panther wakanda forever is
now a worldwide and in this video we're
going to be breaking down the plot
ending and how it ties in with the
comics we released a full post credit
scene breakdown yesterday but in this
video I thought I'd touch on the entire
plot to bring you a full spoiler review
we might retread some of the same ground
but this will be our definite spoiler
cap on wakanda forever spoilers forever
from here on out so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the movie then I
highly recommend that you check out now
if you enjoy the video please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe a breakdowns like this every
day with that out the way welcome to the
heavy spoilers show I'm your host Paul
AKA your favorite color now we'll not
get into that but we will get another
breakdown
little darling don't shed nothing
now the movie begins with a strong focus
on the death of t'challa Chadwick
Boseman of course passed away in 2020
and this massively rocked the world and
the production of the movie Marvel was
stuck between a rock and a hard place
over what to do and Ryan coogler had to
rework his entire script from the ground
up though no more was always going to be
the villain the initial plan was to show
Things From t'challa's perspective as
his kingdom was thrown into war instead
what we get is a story about grief loss
and also acceptance this is set at the
backdrop of two leaders deciding how to
best navigate the rest of the world
gaining the power they have the first
black panther ran it with wakanda
stepping into the Limelight and giving
the rest of the world access to some of
their resources we learned this didn't
include vibranium which they worry will
give the rest of Earth far too much
power now like the first movie there is
a scene where we see a Kanye in raimonda
flying through a force field that
surrounds and camouflages the kingdom
this opens differently to what's come
before allowing people to enter it
easier however the city is still in the
visible from the outside demonstrating
how there's still this lack of trust now
this Gateway also provides a weakness as
it means Italo Canyons can swim under it
only the US had discovered they have
submarines but we'll move on from that
the UN wants to even the odds are made
and early on they attempt to take the
material by force the king is dead and
because of this they think they can
basically do what they want weapons of
mass destruction or ideas that this
movie wrestles with and there's several
ways we can apply this mentality to our
own world people that don't have the
resources and Technology are the ones on
the back foot and this leaves them
vulnerable to others they launch secret
Expeditions and we learn the talocan
also has vibranium too early on we meet
like Belle's character and she leads a
diving operation into a region of the
ocean where the material has been
detected this brings no more into the
fold who has a history with Humanity
that we'll talk about in just a bit now
he sees vibranium as being a Gateway
that people can use to lure themselves
over others it's basically the whole
Twitter verification thing but with
actual consequences really has a way
that everyone can get check marks
through Twitter blue but the more things
that only zedless YouTubers should have
them now Atlantis is also now telecan
which I should have mentioned before
with no more being changed up in several
ways from the comic books I just got my
head around saying name or but there's
name or name or and now my guy will be
called the same thing that people made
photo of me for saying now though he
came before Aquaman all that seems to
matter these days are the movies so it
makes sense that they change things up
and gave him a completely different
style to what we've seen before as for
t'challa handling his death was always
going to be difficult for the team
behind this in the build up to the movie
there were rumors that he would die in
battle and go out in a blaze of glory
however the character passes away off
screen due to an unknown illness I have
seen comments online saying that wakanda
has a cure for cancer in the comics but
I don't actually think that's what's
causing him to deteriorate is also the
fact the actor died in real life so they
have to either swap the actor out or
have him pass away personally I think
they made the right choice and we'll
talk about how this sets up the post
credit scene later assuri was trying to
create a synthetic herb that would cure
him but sadly she doesn't get this far
killmonger of course destroyed all the
herbs in the last movie with the final
one being used to turn to Charla into
black panther now his funeral is
heartbreaking dude obviously being
symbolic of the actual actor's passing
and because of this you couldn't really
feel the emotion in it accordingly with
time where an actors died in real life
that's the head of a franchise like this
and they've also played out his
characters passing on screen too sure
there was Paul Walker and Fast and the
Furious but that send-off was played
more about him riding off into the
sunset the characters in that franchise
don't really face the grief that the
ones do here with this being a central
theme for the film the movie even opens
with shuri demonstrating some of the
stages of grief and we hear her
bargaining with a higher power in the
goddess Bast she says that if the
goddess heals him that you'll never
question her existence again and it it's
a really powerful way to open the film
romonda arrives and shuri immediately
asks what her brother's heart rate is
deep down knowing that he's in fact gone
the funeral is a mega event with
everyone wearing white as a celebration
of his life this spreads beyond the
actors into the Marvel Studios logo
which is now watch with Chadwick
boseman's images and quotes I'm saying a
don't cry challenge right now and if if
you don't get at least a little teary
eye here then you might be a replicant
this video is sponsored by established
titles a fun and novel way to preserve
the natural Woodlands of Scotland while
helping Global reforestation efforts
establish titles lets you call yourself
a lady Lord or a lad due to a
traditional Scottish custom you see
landowners used to refer to themselves
as this and established titles allows
you to buy at least one square foot of
dedicated land and a private estate in
edelston Scotland on top of this it's a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles were planetary with
every single order they work with global
Charities like one tree plan lid and
trees for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst also helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland and it
also comes with a bit of an ego boost on
top of all this environmental stuff you
can officially change your name on
credit cards plane tickets your dating
profile whatever you want they also give
you a certificate confirming your
lordship and a unique plot Number that
confirms your exact plot of land but
before Kevin's spoilers you punk I am
the Lord of this realm now in addition
to this established titles have also
told me that the first 200 people who
use my link in the description below
will be given a plot within walking
distance of mine it makes an amazing
last minute gift and established titles
is actually running a massive Black
Friday sale right now plus if you use
the code heavy spoilers you get an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com heavy spoilers to
get your gifts now and help support the
channel thanks now from here we get a
time Jump of one year and we see shuri
still has an let go she can't burn to
Charlie's robes and this becomes
something that carries a lot of
symbolism the film culminates with her
finally doing this and symbolically it
shows her moving on from his death after
this Nakia brings her into Charles
centimeter and the burning of the robes
with the entrance of this character
shows how she's passed from one chapter
of life to the next and become an auntie
now it's during the scene in which he
initially refuses to burn the clothing
that we're introduced to them all
stop right there who are you and how did
you get in here
this place is amazing
the air is pristine
underwater
my mother told stories about a place
like this a protected land with people
that never had to leave
never have to change who they were
what reason do you have to reveal your
secret to the world I am not a woman who
enjoys or repeating herself who are you
I had many names
my people call me
well my enemies call me no more
once the person responsible for creating
the vibranium tracking device and
believes that the wakonnen should find
the scientist because of t'challa's
Prior actions due to him telling the
world about vibranium it sort of create
a power struggle and he's now seen as
being the one who's responsible after
this he leaves him with a shell device
that can communicate with the Tallow
Kenyans and we get a discussion over
what should happen in the wakandan
throne room this features the last
performance of Dorothy Steele who too
sadly passed away during the production
of this movie now there's a couple of
nice that Easter eggs laced throughout
the opening of the movie and the first
one of these that I want to discuss is
the AI sure he makes her own and I'm
guessing that this comes from Vision she
studied the Mind stun in Infinity War
and the AI appears like Yellowstone
which of course links back to that the
stone combined Ultron Jarvis Tony and
Bruce's personalities along with visions
and it seems like she created one when
building the new tech there's also news
reports with Anderson Cooper and along
the bottom we can see a mention of
Scotland's book this is called look out
for the little guy and if you've seen a
leaked d23 trailer for Quantum Mania
which you're bad boy then you'll know
that he reads this at one point later on
we also see one discussing you as God
which is of course building off the back
of thorleman Thunder now With a Little
Help from Everett Ross sure and Akai
appointed to Boston which is where they
meet Riri Williams
oh
she debuted all the way back in
Invincible Iron Man vol 3 Issue 7 and
Riri is a genius that gained early
admission to MIT she stands as one of
the smartest Minds in the Marvel
Universe and we of course know that
she's getting it as the Plus show in the
source material she built her own suit
of armor using outdated Iron Man parts
and also things that she picked up in
the scraps of MIT this led to security
trying to confront air only for her to
escape in a model 1 suit which is
similar to Tony's Mark 1 and the movie
changes things up a bit as she's
basically using leftover car parts she
also has a heart-shaped Arc Reactor and
if you look at her suit at the end then
you might notice the way the shoulders
are positioned it makes a little it
makes a little heart shape she also has
a scene similar to Iron Man's first
flight where the altitude gets to her
and causes her to fall from the sky now
after a big chase slash fight scene with
the government and Tallow canyons shuri
and Riri are taken to the underwater
Kingdom on the surface Akai is stripped
of a title and Ramona goes to meet
nakira out in Haiti now as you may
mentioned earlier the credit scene
revealed that she and t'challa had a son
together who is also called t'challa
well she and his father agreed that they
didn't want him being exposed to the
world at this point in his young life
knowing that he would be dying the
burden of royalty would be even more
intense at such a young age and
therefore they ended up hiding him away
this is another reason why Nakia didn't
go to the funeral because she would have
to take him with him and this would end
up revealing him Nakia and young
t'challa had their own ceremony for him
in Haiti and he's remained there ever
since that now I've seen people agreeing
and disagreeing with his decision and I
think that no matter what Marvel did it
would have annoyed someone the real-life
death of an actor is something that's so
difficult to handle and I think even if
they'd recast him it would it would have
brought up comparisons to Chadwick and
yeah it's just so hard to navigate I
think this was probably the best thing
they could have done and yeah like I
said if he completely recast him you run
the risk of that actor and not living up
to Chadwick or making it seem like he
was easily replacing possible I know
they have been recasting the MCU and
that William Hurt is getting one in his
passing with Harrison Ford but yeah
there's no playbook for this thing or
where that they can basically please
everyone the way it plays out I view him
as being as someone who can live out the
original planned stories for t'challa
without it necessarily erasing what's
come before instead it's carrying on his
legacy and it allows Shoei to be the
Black Panther for some time before she
hands over the mantle now due to the fox
merger Disney also now own the rights of
the X-Men as well a while back there was
some disappointment that t'challa was
with Nikia rather than being with storm
like how he is in the comics by that
this is Charlie could grow up and marry
her with the X-Men movies still being
some time off they could bring in a
younger storm and have them grow up
alongside each other now we also learned
that young t'challa has been going under
the name Toussaint this could actually
be another
who was a Haitian General that fought
for the country's Independence I think
that's why Sherry says there's a lot of
history with his name and if that's the
case it's also also a nice addition to
his character anyway total side tangent
there and after they've just been
captured we see that no more he's
actually a nice guy he's a pretty nice
guy and the backstory is filled in and
we learned that centuries ago his people
found a magical air but that could heal
him nemour's mother was pregnant with
him when she took it and this somewhat
altered his physiology you see the herb
I'm gonna say herb I say it but to Panda
to Americans but I'm just gonna say her
the herb kind of has a double side to it
and those are take it wake ups and what
reborn they start to gravitate towards
the water and this could somewhat be
tied in with her own Evolution life on
the planet came from the sea and they
get Cravings to return to the water
herbs of course massively played into
black panther and sure he ends up using
the Tallow Canyon one in order to
complete her synthetic one much in the
same way that that one helped to advance
wakanda you also see how talocan is a
mirror of it similar to the kingdom it
too had vibranium along with the herb
both these civilizations advanced now I
loved exploring telokan along with them
all and they have changed it up from
Atlantis like how it is in the source
material Aquaman of course made over a
billion dollars and though he and them
all are very similar in the comics they
changed him up here so he's distinctive
from his DC counterpart no more has been
confirmed to be over 500 years old and
he's also been nicknamed the boy without
love I heard from one of my sources that
there's a deleted scene where someone
asks him what is love and he says baby
don't hurt me don't hurt me no more
don't try your teeth
I was a character and I'm always
introduced all the way back in 1939
before Marvel had even been founded he
debuted in the motion picture's funny
weekly issue 1 where we watched Ernest
Shackleton on a deep sea Voyage similar
to what happened with Lake Bell who no
idea what she's called and I apologize
for that now along the way he on Earth
no more which is why he's called in the
comics and he ended up fighting against
the Nazis in World War II at the German
divers were discovered near Atlantis he
fought alongside Captain America and the
original Human Torch but obviously they
don't have that backstory here he's
fought against the Fantastic Four and
he's normally an anti-hero that has no
problem working with and also against
the good guys I can't see him being
brought in with a Fantastic Four in the
future and in the comics he's a major
Sue storm Sim that could end up slying
in the a38 universe's DMS now she's
officially a single mother he's also
been a member of the Illuminati the
illumawati but the group were pretty
crap and in Civil War they ended up
falling up part like 838 Reed Richards
oh see you chump now more is said to be
a mutant in the movie which again
we already have the Deadpool 3
announcement that will see Hugh Jackman
returning as Wolverine and therefore
they are slowly starting to come into
the MCU with Miss Muller being the first
acknowledged one I kind of get the
feeling that we're building towards
Avengers vs X-Men once the whole Secret
Wars stuff is over and the movie
actually gives an odd to that graphic
novel in it Neymar attacks wakanda with
a tidal wave which is to something that
ends up happening in the film whether we
get this stuff with Fantastic Four down
the line remains to be seen and I just
hope that they don't water down the
potential for the character animore's
mother dies sometime after they build a
life under the water and they return to
the surface so that she can be buried on
the land however here they discover that
in the time between the people of being
colonized Neymar destroys the foes there
and this is why he carries a hatred for
Humanity just don't let him see the
internet yeah Ultron took one look at
Twitter he said [ __ ] it these guys gotta
go now Under the Sea he built a kingdom
and this is gone under the radar for
several decades whether this links in
with the under water earthquake
mentioned in endgame is something we
don't get confirmed but I'm pretty sure
it does it may Marvel sometimes they
don't like to handheld people but
looking back at that scene with a Kaye
I'm guessing that they're linked animal
fears that a wall with a surface is
inevitable and he wants to form an
alliance with wakanda when the time
comes do you want to form an alliance
with me however Riri gotta go Shiri
refuses this but maybe you could have
just called She-Hulk and got her to
rewrite the entire MCU now during this
time no more shows show you around and
we see the underwater tunnels at the
talo Canyons use to travel around
another sea my man is a charmer so I can
see how he laid pipe and the entire
kingdom is such a cool addition to the
MCU nikira is tasked with saving the
captives but it looks like an attack by
wakanda due to her killing a God now
because of this no more feels like it
was wrong to trust wakanda so he
declares war on the nation wakanda is
attacked by giant waves and several of
namor's forces this leads to the death
of ramonda who sadly dies while saving
Riri from the same fate really emotional
gut punch to the film and there's of
course a ton of oscarbons around her
performance which is so cool to see
Marvel phase 4 needs a win and with his
being the last film of this stage I'm
hoping it at least goes out on a high it
could flood the Oscars in hell now a big
thing that we discover in the film is
that Everett Ross and Val are in fact
married never would have put them
together and I kind of wish he'd stayed
waking up at the crack of dawn anyone
for the UK heads now Ross has been
giving Intel to wakanda and his ex-wife
has him arrested after the Queen's death
the movie ends with him being broken out
of prison by akoye and his next
appearance will be in secret amazing
he's working with Nick Fury to try and
oust the hidden Scrolls in the
government and as Val is also in secret
invasion in the comics I think we can
sort of make some Theory times over
what's going on there now in the comics
it was revealed that Val was actually a
scroll that was mascara writing I'd say
so it wasn't really valid but it was in
fact a scroll it was her and Nick Fury
that were getting it on and she tried to
kill him but he did it first which is
when it was revealed that she was
actually a shapeshifter this is what
clued him into the invasion as well and
potentially they've switched things up
with Ross here to make it so that he
discovers it on top of this we also have
the potential that we'll be getting a
midnight Angel's tie-in there's long
been rumors that we'll be getting a
Disney plus series based on them without
being brought into the mainstream here
it could be setting that up now we also
know that Val is gonna form the
Thunderbolts and that she will lead the
group in the MCU in case you don't know
they're basically Marvel Sansa to The
Suicide Squad they're more anti-heroes
here than out and out villains like they
are in the comics but it's gonna be
interesting to see what they do with the
characters going forward anyway after
the death of raimonda shui ends up
continuing her work on the synthetic
herb killmonger of course destroyed all
the real ones in the first movie and the
final one was used to give to Chola his
strength back she finally develops this
and a Ponte taking it she travels to the
ancestral plane here we get a Space Jam
Legacy Cameo with Michael Jordan sorry
Michael B Jordan killmonger is here and
not to Charlotte because at this point
mentally sure he has the potential to be
a cruel and ruthless leader just like
him this leads to a great exchange
between the two Noah killmonger Cameo
was one of the obvious things that would
be getting in the movie it's still great
seeing his return sure he goes back
empowered and she makes a new suit the
wakondans have retreated to him bakus in
the mountains because waves can't go
that high and Baku knows that his people
view Neymar as a god killing him will
lead him or Bloodshed and basically it's
not really a role that they want to
travel down
will risk Eternal War now this is a
giant water Serpent and the design of
this can be seen in his headdress sure
he doesn't care though as she's lost her
father brother Mother and Kingdom
realizing that the more gets his
strength from the water they decide to
dehydrate him which takes us into the
finale using a giant ship on the wall
using a giant ship on the water they
learn more into a moisture trap device
that makes the king drip as we know
prince Andrew is the only royal family
member who doesn't sweat and therefore
this thirst trap works on him in the
comics the atlanteans can only survive
out of water for a matter of minutes
which is why they have to wear the
breathing apparatus all right nemour is
a meeting which is why he doesn't carry
the blue skin they do he can breathe
oxygen but he still requires water to
survive the ship crashes on a deserted
Beach and shuri ends up fighting him no
more stabs are at one point making it
seem like she might die but remembering
her time on the astral plane she uses
killmonger's words to push her through
shuri wins and has invested but she
realizes that if she kills him it will
set her down a darker path this
escalates things with talocan even more
and pushes her past the point of no
return his cycle of Revenge will begin
and in an Abby and Ellie moment she
decides not to go through with it sure
he talks about vengeance consuming them
after seeing a vision of raimonda in
this line of course links back to the
ending of Civil War in that t'challa
said something similar to Zemo and he
refused to let Benjamins consume him
just like sure he does here the
performer truce and no more goes to lead
his people all the ones that died at
this point probably will feel a bit good
but the two sides kneel to their leaders
no more does get questioned at one point
whether this makes him seem weak like a
like a sort of King viserys but my man
says he's not armless and I have to hand
it to him he hasn't fallen off sorry
that that's a leftover House of the
Dragon joke but one day they realize
either they'll need wakanda or wakanda
will need them so finally finally they
form that Alliance yes now there are a
couple of extra things we see happening
at the end mbaka goes to the waterfall
once more like how he did in the first
movie and with shuri not showing up
shuri this means that he's now the king
now sure he also fixes up riri's car and
she sends her back to Boston minus the
suit this could explain why she ends up
having to build her own and will likely
see that playing out in the Disney plus
series ashiri visits nakira in Haiti
where she finally burns the white
clothes on the beach and says goodbye
this is when we meet t'challa's son and
discover that romondo met him too though
t'challa is gone his legacy will
continue we're unsure what's happening
next in The wakanda Saga but we now have
a current queen and black panther along
with an heir who can come in and take
the mantle down the line not a dry eye
in the house for this scene unless
you've got a Heart Made of Stone and
that ends the movie and I'm not I'm not
crying
and when I wake up
as for my opinion on the film the first
thing I thought when leaving the movie
was is this better than best picture
nominee black panther I think I probably
enjoyed it more but I think that
original film definitely had more High
moments this felt more solid overall but
it suffered from a third act problem
that a lot of Marvel movies do the setup
and character studies early on are way
more interesting for me than the final
fighter Marvel have which tend to evolve
into just CGI action scenes you can tell
the pandemic affected the VFX here too
as there's some really bad green screen
along with the iron hot helmet tracking
that just seems off when it unmasks the
minor criticisms but the more simple
fight on the beach was way more
impactful to me than the big army vs
Army one on the boat obviously action
scenes like this are something that
everyone feels like they have to include
in these movies but I think the best
part are the character studies talocan
was incredible to see play out and the
killmonger ancestral plane scene
elevated the movie so much seeing really
trying to get over her brother's death
is one of the strongest character arcs
in the MCU as she feels like a failure
due to not finding a cure she's
constantly pushed to the point of
breaking and Leticia Wright handles the
material really well she can do both a
humorous and dramatic scenes with ease
and though Angela is getting the Oscar
talk I actually think that Leticia
should too Angela is incredible as well
and Dominic Thorne makes a great debut
as Riri I like no more too and there's a
real human level to him beneath all the
bravado now Disney are constantly going
on about representation and in the
lead-up to the movie they made a big
point of saying how anaka and AO were in
a relationship together it's one of the
things they push to the Forefront of the
promotion of the film but it's also
clear that this was one of the first
things I cut I feel like Disney are just
throwing bones to the gay community to
try and get them to feel like they're
being seen but to me this studio needs
to either do a properly a stop promoting
it like they're so Progressive when they
literally had a forehead kiss and Ayo
calling him I love I'm not gay so if you
are and disagree let me know below but I
think if it was me I'd feel like they're
not doing a good enough job they pat
themselves on the back so much about it
and though it's another nitpick I just
think why are you guys bigging yourself
up when you you've really done nothing
this happened with rise of Skywalker and
light year as well and seems like
they're doing it to use it as a talking
point to promote the movie to gay people
rather than doing it because they want
to make actual stories involving them
also I recognize I'm a white guy
reviewing this movie so it might not
speak to me as much as it speaks to you
now there's gonna be people that love it
and as a tribute I think it works really
well as a movie it's also pretty good
and it is one of the stronger Phase 4
Films where it ranks amongst the other
MCU films though this doesn't crack the
top 10 for me and I don't know whether
it's a movie that I'm gonna race back to
watch seen it twice now so obviously I
did race back to watch it uh but that
was that was for these videos and both
times I laughed and cried but the length
dull those emotions a bit instead of
sticking with me throughout had a really
good start and a really good final few
scenes with the middle sort of being
your standard MCU Affair your mileage
may vary and everyone's gonna have their
own Thoughts with this no doubt being
another divisive MCU movie I'm scoring
it at 7.5 you know what I might I might
move it up to an eight but sort of in
that so it's in that zone and there let
me know your thoughts on the film below
now we are in competition right now
giving away three copies of top gun
Maverick on the 15th of November and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film we picked the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch make sure you
check out our breakdown of the post
credit scene which is going to be linked
on screen right now we talk about what
was originally well apparently meant to
be in the film what the ending means and
also just touch upon little things where
we think the MCU is going to be going
without the way hope you enjoy your
weekend you take yourself I'll see you
next time peace also don't hate me for
giving it a seven slash eight out of ten
yeah please